you know there's one thing I want to say
just just at the top here that's I in
the past have been critical of Trump's
some of trumps rhetoric about the media
I've found that some of it has been a
bit overblown even dangerous at times
and although I I agree in general with
his criticisms of the media I agree with
anyone's criticisms in general of the
left-wing media but I you know I thought
that some of it was overblown
however these last few weeks with the
Cavanaugh story have I think vindicated
everything that Trump has ever said
about the media he's exactly right in
fact actually he could probably go even
further in his criticisms than he has
gone when you see what the media is done
here they have with this Kavanaugh story
and of course it's not the first time
they've done this but it's just been so
striking they have completely discarded
any semblance of integrity objectivity
decency honesty ethics they've just
gotten rid of all of that and now this
is a straight-up in-your-face blatant
explicit smear campaign to destroy Brett
Kavanaugh because he's not pro-abortion
that's what's going on with the media so
just another example of that if you
happen to be watching NBC or MSNBC on
Monday nights I don't know why you would
do that but if you did you would have
seen an interview with Julie sweat Nick
now Julie sweat Nick is the mentally
unbalanced woman who's accused Brett
Kavanaugh of engaging in systemic gang
rapes and and in fact paints a portrait
of their high school years where as a
time when there was just gang rapes
going on all the time every weekend
there will be gang raped parties and all
the girls would come for some reason to
these gang rape parties and then they
would be gang raped and but they would
keep coming back and Julie sweat Nick
even though she's three years older but
she would come to these high school gang
rape parties that she kept coming and
then she was gang raped and then she
kept coming back
more you didn't after that so that's our
accusation and ever since she released
those accusations through Michael
avenatti who's a just a scumbag lying
attention-starved pretend lawyer ever
since those accusations last week we
found out that well she's there was a
restraining order her her ex-boyfriend
tried to get her straining order against
her because he says that she threatened
him and threatened his his child we find
out these you know he's a she was
accused by her employer of making up
false sexual harassment claims and what
the employer says is that she made up
false this this I think is important
actually according to her employer back
I think it was maybe about 18 20 years
ago she made up false sexual harassment
claims because she had been sexually
harassing a couple of men at work and
when they went and told on her she made
up this claim as in retaliation so and
then there are other other details as
well anyway so when MSNBC decides let's
do an interview with her now they say
they tell us two things number one they
could not confirm or corroborate
anything she said nothing they could not
confirm a single detail that she told
them and number two they also admit that
what she says in the interview does not
line up with the with the allegation
that she released even a week ago she's
already changed her story yet they
decided to air this interview anyway I
mean this this goes beyond just
journalistic malpractice this everyone
at NBC involved with airing this
interview should be fired and sued for
all the money they have because of this
I mean this is crazy so they know they
know that this is not a credible story
they know that it cannot be confirmed
they have to know because if they if
they have brains in their heads they
know that the story is just insane and
ridiculous on its face and they know
she's already changed her story in a
week and yet they come out they air the
interview anyway because it none of that
matters to them they just want to get it
out there because they know that there
are gonna be a lot of stupid people
watching who will see the interview even
with the disclaimers of oh we couldn't
confirm anything she changed story a lot
of stupid people are gonna see the
interview and that's not going to matter
to them they're gonna they're just going
to glom on to these to these lurid
details and so that's all they're
interested in doing now I want to let me
read just one clip from this interview
this is what sweat Nix says now pay
attention to the words that she uses she
says talking at Kavanagh he was very
aggressive very sloppy drunk a mean
drunk I saw him go up to girls and paw
on them and tried to you know get a
little too handsy touching them on
private parts I saw him try to shift
clothing I don't know what that means
I saw him push girls against walls he
would pretend to stumble and push and
stumble into them and knock them against
walls he would push his body against
hers now if you've been following these
this story that like that paragraph
there sounds very familiar doesn't
what's wet Nick has done is she has just
repeated verbatim all the things that
the media has already reported and the
allegations that have already been
reported about about Kavanagh in the
last week she's just taking those
allegations and repeating them verbatim
sloppy drunk mean drunk well that's
exactly what a couple of his
acquaintances in college said about
those are the exact terms they used
sloppy drunk mean drunk very aggressive
well that's what the media has been
saying that all week especially after
his after he you know had the gall to be
angry at false allegations against
himself at the hearing and so there's a
how he's aggressive so she said that to
pushed against walls well that was
another unsubstantiated ridiculous
charge that someone came up with a 1998
you know that was released last week in
1998 supposedly he pushed somebody
against the wall when he was drunk so
she's just taking this she's just
repeating what she read
what she saw on cable news she's
repeating it back to them and they and
they aired the interview I mean it's so
yeah fake news I would say so
whatever whatever Trump is said about
them I think they have earned all of
those labels and then some now so we
heard yesterday from Rachel Mitchell
who's the prosecutor that was recruited
by Republicans to question
Christine Ford at the hearing and she
came out with a very thorough report
where she's talking about all the many
holes in Fords testimony and she says in
fact that the case it's not even that he
said she said the case according to rich
Rachel Mitchell now keep in mind Rachel
Mitchell is a sex crimes prosecutor so
she is you know she knows the law but
she also deals with these kinds of
claims all the time this is what she
does so she hears these kinds of claims
all the time she could she can
differentiate between credible claims
and not credible and she's saying as
someone who does this every day these
are not credible in fact she says it's
even weaker than it he said she said and
that no reasonable prosecutor would
bring a case based on the story that she
tells so she released this memo the
memos is is just devastating for Ford
and for Democrats or it would be
devastating if the media would report on
it which they haven't of course because
they're too busy listening to you know
Julie sweat Nick talk about the gang
rapes but very very devastating and she
goes through all of the inconsistencies
and Ford story there quite a lot of them
want to read here's a want to read some
of her bullet points on that on in
particular now she talks about all that
you get this is he but she also
discusses inconsistencies in memory
lapses and blank spots from just the
last few months
forget about 35 years ago for just the
last few months so here are some of the
bullet points from that part of the memo
talking about the last few months
reading now from The Daily wires report
on this it's
as dr. Ford has struggled to recall
important recent events relating to her
allegations and her testimony regarding
recent events raises further questions
about her memory dr. Ford struggled to
remember her interactions with the
Washington Post dr. Ford could not
remember if she showed a full or partial
set of therapy notes to the Washington
Post she does not remember whether she
showed the Post report of the therapist
notes or her own summary of those notes
she does not remember if she actually
had a copy of the notes when she texted
The Washington Post on July 6th dr. Ford
refused to provide any of her therapy
therapy notes to the committee dr.
Ford's explanation of why she disclosed
her allegations the way she did raises
questions
she claimed originally that she wished
at first story to remain confidential
but the person operating the tip line at
the Washington Post was the first person
other than her therapist or husband to
whom she disclosed the identity of her
alleged attacker she testified that she
had a sense of urgency to relay the
information to the Senate she did not
contact the Senate however because she
claimed she didn't know how to do that
but she doesn't explain how she knew how
to contact her congresswoman but not her
senator I mean presumably she just went
online and googled it and then and then
went through the jails but she said she
didn't know how to do that with her
senator she couldn't she could figure
how to google that but she could Google
or congresswoman dr. foot could not
remember if she was being audio or video
recorded when she took the polygraph and
she could not remember whether the
polygraph occurred the same day as her
grandmother's funeral or the day after
her grandmother's funeral and then also
it notes that it would have been
inappropriate to administer a polygraph
to someone who was grieving that's
actually a really good point I mean no
competent polygraph examiner would give
you a polygraph on the day that you come
home from a funeral for your grandmother
I mean there's no note that's a joke
nobody would do that because a polygraph
is measuring all of the you know - you
know it's the things that it's measuring
if you're if you're know if polygraphs
were actually real science which they
aren't but if you're grieving that's
gonna mess up the whole thing so there
are a lot of really important points and
this is not just about poking holes in
her memory
there's also the whole thing about the
therapists notes now we only know she's
telling us that she told this story to
her therapist and that she even and then
well maybe she mentioned Cavanaugh's
name to a therapist maybe she didn't she
says she doesn't remember husband says
she did whatever but we only know that
because she's telling us that she's
claiming that she told her therapist
about this right she claims that she
told her therapist at least the whole
story even if she didn't mention the
guy's name
so obviously the question is well can we
see those notes can we see what you
actually told your therapist to make
sure number one that you really told
your therapist at all you didn't make
that up and number two did the story
you're told you told your therapist does
it line up well we already know it
doesn't line up completely because the
number of people involved this change
but you know for instance I mean this is
just just hypothetical but what if she
told her therapist the story but then
said something like yeah I don't you
know indicated that she wasn't actually
sure completely who did it right I mean
just hypothetically how do we know that
that's not in the notes well because she
won't give us the notes well then it's
sort of relevant to know that well you
say you don't want to give the notes
it's personal private okay but you gave
to the Washington Post then she says
well I don't remember if I gave it to
the Washington Post oh you don't
remember I feel like you'd remember that
I mean how do you not remember that this
is a huge moment in your life you're
talking to the media about this thing
that you're sayings traumatize you all
this time you don't remember that
conversation
what and I would think sending them your
therapist notes that's a kind of very
vulnerable it's not something you do
every day you know you don't send your
therapist notes to media outlets every
day it's the kind of thing that she I
mean you either did it or you didn't I
think you remember doing it if you did
oh she doesn't remember so I think we
are clear to speculate either that she
never gave her therapist notes to anyone
so there's so her what she's telling us
about
she told her therapist could be
completely bogus or she did give her
therapist notes to the Washington Post
and now those notes are being hidden for
some reason either way doesn't look good
for now here I think is that is the and
I I talked about this last week but I
want to focus in on it again I think the
most important potential lie the most
important inconsistency or hole in the
story that could possibly be a lie is
this and Mitchell points it out in her
memo Ford claims to not remember how she
got home from the party after the
alleged assault occurred this detail is
very crucial because the house she says
was near a Country Club and we know that
the country club was a 20-minute drive
from her home it was like six or seven
miles right which if you're going
residential roads might take you 20
months so that means that someone had to
pick her up and drive her home there's
no way that she walked seven miles home
and if she did walk seven miles home
after according to her or after being
sexually assaulted I think that seven
mile walk home she would remember that
but she doesn't remember how she got
home so we we could only assume that she
was driven home by someone so somebody
picked her up the testimony of that
person would be indispensable because
they could describe Ford's physical and
emotional state at the time according to
her allegation she was a 15 year old
girl who had just been violently
assaulted and in her mind was almost
killed she said she thought she was
going to die okay she fled the house
fearing for her life then she got into
somebody's car that person surely would
have noticed that Ford was in distress
okay
maybe Ford it wouldn't have told the
person maybe the perfor was said I'm
fine
but whoever that person was they would
be able to tell okay this girl's crying
she's mean she she's obviously
distressed about something now the main
reason why why
Juanita Broderick's allegation against
Bill Clinton was and is so believable
incredible is that Broderick was found
by her friends moments after Clinton
allegedly raped her and those friends
have come out and corroborated her
account and they confirmed that she did
you know that they did find Broderick
crying and in a state of shock on the
night in question
now Broderick also told them at the time
Bill Clinton did this to me which I mean
which basically makes it a hundred
percent like did this it happened right
but even if she hadn't even if she had
even if she had said something horrible
happen me but she didn't she didn't give
specifics or does she didn't say who it
was
the fact that she was found by her
friends on that day bleeding bruised
crying in a state of shock I mean that
is very significant evidence in her
favor is it is it believable that a
fifteen-year-old girl could pull herself
together and present herself as totally
fine moments after running out of a
house to escape two drunken rapists no
it is not believable not at all
it just isn't we must then logically
conclude either that somebody witnessed
Ford in a state of shock or that nobody
witnessed it because it didn't happen
now for claims she can't remember who
picked her up but she remembers hiding
in the bathroom after the assault she
remembers hearing the two boys laughing
and talking as they left the room she
remembers running down the stairs she
remembers leaving the house she
remembers the whole chain of events
right before she opened the door to
somebody's car and then what her memory
goes completely blank at that very
convenient moment well that's that's
actually not exactly correct because she
doesn't she doesn't remember the whole
chain because
presumably she called somebody she would
have had to call somebody to pick her up
and this was before cell phones she
would have had to use a landline so
either she so she says she ran right out
of the house well she she must have gone
into the kitchen first to use the
landline or she went to somebody else's
house or something went to a payphone I
mean but but again if she's walking down
the street searching for a payphone or
if she's knocking on someone else's door
to use a phone she would remember that
but she she would had to call somebody
unless she had already arranged for
someone to pick her up and it just so
happened coincidentally that that person
happened to show up right after she had
been sexually assaulted which again is
hard to believe so she would had to call
somebody cook but she doesn't remember
what must have been a rather panic phone
call and she doesn't remember what had
to have been the most uncomfortable and
difficult car ride of her life but she
remembers that the house was sparsely
furnished and she remembers precisely
how many beers she consumed which she
says was only one now her memory may be
spotty right it was a long time ago but
it is very interesting that key details
which could corroborate her account just
so happen to be completely blocked from
her memory
you may even call that suspicious you
may even say that this is a clear
indication that she is lying and besides
even if she doesn't remember getting
into somebody's car right after the
assault what about the person behind the
wheel why haven't they come forward do
we have two cases of convenient amnesia
happening at the same time around the
same event the only way okay that a
person might forget about the time that
they picked up a traumatized 15 year old
girl is if there was no indication that
she was traumatized but if there's no
indication of it then that would seem to
punch a humungous hole in Ford's story
but that brings us back to the question
of whether or not it's believable that
a girl you know might conceivably run
out of a house fleeing to drunken
rapists and then get into somebody's car
and not give off any vibes at all that
she had suffered some kind of terrible
experience that's just again it's hard
to believe it's especially hard to
believe us assuming that the person who
picked her up was either her a parent or
one of her friends unless she hitchhiked
or unless she called a cab to pick her
up the story doesn't add up you know if
I mean you feel like you've got a good
chance that we've been a parent to pick
her up at the age of 15
well look I know that kids can hide
things from their parents but if you
pick your daughter up mere moments after
she was just sexually assaulted you're
gonna notice that something is going
wrong or if you're if you're a girl and
you pick up one of your girlfriends
you're gonna notice
and it seems extremely likely that your
friend's gonna tell you something
happened but either they don't tell you
you're gonna notice something was wrong
but nobody's come out no one's come out
to say yeah you know what aye-aye-aye I
did I did pick up Christine Ford you
know I remember and she didn't tell me
what happened but she was she was
obviously distressed about something
nobody's come out to say that now wait a
second here though I'm saying that it's
it's unreasonable to think that she was
able to completely pull herself together
to the point where nobody would notice
that something was amiss well she
actually admits that she didn't pull
herself together she testifies that her
grades in college suffered because of
the attack now oddly enough the attack
happened when she was 15 and she had two
more years of high school in front of
her she doesn't say anything about her
high school grades suffering which is
interesting which would seem to indicate
that her high school grades were fine so
if you were to go back back and look at
her high school days you would see that
she did fine and then she gets into
college
poorly for a couple of years and we're
supposed to believe that that was
because of the sexual assault that had
happened three years before but in the
intervening three years you were fine I
mean what what um but that again I think
shows shows calculation in her testimony
like she's going back and she's thinking
okay I know that I did well in high
school so I can but I didn't do by I did
get bad grades first two years of
college someone could go look that up
and see oh look that vindicates me but
you know the real point is that she says
she was devastated
at the time to the point where her
academics suffered let's pretend that
that's true okay so let's go beyond the
car ride then let's assume that she did
hitch a ride home with a stranger and
that the stranger has since you know
moved to Mars or died or something okay
fine well well what about the night when
she got home and she saw her parents or
the next day
what about school on Monday what about
the next week or month or a year or
three years or five years or ten years
she said she was traumatized this whole
time why has nobody come forward and
said yet you know Christine she she
never told us what happened but she did
change there was a sudden change in her
in her behavior you know something was
wrong right I mean there was she ever
ething was fine and then and then and
then and then all of a sudden she just
no one has come out to say that nobody
yet she claims number one she was
traumatized and number two there was
there were outward signs of her trauma
in in the form at least of bad grades
nobody though who knows her has come out
and said that her where her or her
parents are alive as far as I know what
where parents have said nothing have you
noticed that nobody in her family has
come out to say to say anything to vouch
for her at all and the even if she
didn't tell them I mean these are really
important witnesses right they could and
they could tell you something about her
mental state at the time but they say
nothing
that is that is very curious isn't it so
there you go
III think with with there are a lot of
holes in the story but that particular
hole you know the the fact that nobody
nobody has come out to vouch for this
idea that she was traumatized we have
not heard from whoever this mystery
person was who picked her up from the
scene of her sexual assault you know if
we want to be generous to Christine Ford
we could say that well you know memory
lapses so on and so forth uh I think
we're at a point now where this is more
than memory lapses she is hiding
something she is at a minimum hiding
something
what is she hiding and why and then as a
as a corollary tight question who has
been coaching her about what information
to say and what information to keep
hidden all right we'll leave it there
Godspeed